[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a steampunk film called
mortal engines
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the movie is set far in
the future at the beginning of the movie
a voice tells us about the most
devastating war mankind has ever faced
in history called the 60 minutes war a
war that only lasted for 60 minutes but
shattered the earth's crust into a
thousand pieces that rearranged the
former continents the few remaining
humans formed mobile cities called
traction cities the cities which can
move on wheels when needed as several
such cities were established a system
called municipal darwinism came into
order according to municipal darwinism
the larger cities called the predators
could hunt the smaller ones and take
over their resources for survival at the
beginning of the movie a girl hiding her
face under a scarf is overlooking the
mountains using her telescope she sees
the massive city of london approaching
her way and runs back to her town called
salshaken salzheiken is being attacked
by the larger predator city london as
the officials find out about london
approaching them everyone in the town
gets to work the engines start and
within seconds the town transforms
itself into a vehicle ready to set off
london closes in on salzekin while it
tries to escape in london many civilians
enjoy overviewing the chase as they
cheer for their city to win the lord
mayor of london is named magnus chrome
he commands the operators on what
measures to take people from solshaken
try their best to escape but ultimately
get caught under chrome's command the
town is then ingested into the predator
city inside london we see various
infrastructures it has museums where
statues of minions are praised as
american deities it is revealed that
people interpreted the aftermath of the
60-minute war however they pleased tom
natsworthy is a low-class apprentice
historian of london he works at the
london museum
that day catherine valentine the
daughter of deputy lord mayor
thaddeus valentine awaits tom for a
history lesson tom is late to assist
catherine but unlike other elites she is
friendly and kind to him the two walk
around the museum looking at historic
things like smartphones and computers
when catherine shows interest in the
60-second war tom shows her a video of
the war that he was able to retrieve
from an old hard drive tom explains that
a quantum energy weapon called the
medusa was used to fight the war and was
the reason the earth was shattered into
pieces he then reveals that the museum
has several weapon texts but bits and
pieces of them have been going missing
frequently since his seniors don't
respond to his concerns about the
missing tech he has kept the weapons in
a locker of his own so they wouldn't be
stolen outside the room tom's senior
herbert eavesdrops on their conversation
he demotes tom to a lower level of the
city but catherine accompanies him
meanwhile the people from saalshaken are
made to evacuate their city which is to
be demolished later they are told to
bring their belongings with them and are
restricted from bringing any weapons
however the girl with the scarf manages
to smuggle in a knife tom and catherine
come to the lowest zone where the people
of solshaken are being checked their job
is to gather new electronics that the
salsakin has tom is fascinated to see a
toaster that is of the highest kind just
then deputy lord mayor and catherine's
father valentine praises tom for knowing
so much about technology as they talk a
worker brings a dangerous old tech
device used in nuclear weapons and hands
it to valentine the way valentine talks
about the weapon unsettles tom meanwhile
the girl with the scarf approaches
valentine as he talks to the people the
girl stabs him saying that this is for
her mother pandora shaw
valentine is shocked to hear the name
before the girl can make another strike
tom stops her and chases after her as
she runs away both end up in the town of
solshaken which is now being demolished
they somehow managed to get past the
demolisher and to the waste chute the
girl falls into the chute but is caught
by tom who is intrigued to see a nasty
scar on her face she tells him her name
is hester shaw and that valentine
murdered her mother right before letting
go of his hand hester then falls into
the chute before valentine arrives at
the place tom asks him about pandora
shaw and looks at valentine in suspicion
at last valentine pushes tom to the
waste chute after hester and acts
innocent when his daughter arrives later
catherine and valentine are in his
chamber when she asks him about pandora
shaw he dismisses her question but
catherine is sure he is hiding something
from her meanwhile tom lands unconscious
on the outskirts of an unknown location
and hester robs him of his money when he
wakes up she leaves him behind but tom
follows her she is furious at tom for
ruining the plan she had been working on
for the past six months tom asks her to
help him get back to london because that
is his home but hester ignores him and
continues walking back in london the
lord mayor is furious at valentine for
bringing them to europe because of which
they are running low on food and water
valentine brings up his energy project
and claims that it is the only thing
that can help london but the lord mayor
is skeptical of his plan at night hester
and tom are resting when they are
attacked by some scavengers from the
south who hunt people an old couple with
their land roving vehicle come to their
aid and save them from the scavengers
they even give the two a tiny room to
rest hester was hurt while trying to
save tom from the scavengers earlier she
dresses her wound to some extent and
lies down a while later she tells tom
that her mother pandora shaw was an
archaeologist who loved to dig up buried
tech of the past she worked closely with
valentine who was always fascinated by
her findings until one day pandora dug
up something that valentine wanted and
that she didn't want him to have
that day he killed pandora and sliced
hester's face in the process hester also
mentions a necklace that pandora handed
her before asking her to run away a
single tear rolls down her cheek as she
finishes telling the story meanwhile
back in london valentine visits the
repurposed saint paul's cathedral where
he is secretly developing the nuclear
weapon medusa the historic tech that has
gone missing from the museum was stolen
by valentine for the same purpose he has
realized that the small cities to hunt
are starting to vanish and soon london
will have no food and resources hence he
wants to strike the non-moving kingdom
of shan guo an anti-traction city that
has all the resources london will need
for hundreds of years however shang guo
is firmly protected by the shield wall
so valentine wants to create medusa to
destroy it and take over the city
after that valentine hears the news of a
cyborg being found in the seas by a
small town he visits the creature when
one of his companions tells him he will
be of use to kill hester the creature is
captured in a case and tells valentine
that hester has broken a promise she
made to him because of which he wants to
kill her hearing this valentine lets the
creature go in the meantime catherine
visits tom's friend beavis to ask him
what her father is hiding from her
beavis somehow knows that valentine
pushed tom into the chute catherine
almost doesn't believe him when beavis
adds that her father is also running a
secret project in return for the
information she offers to show him the
historic tech that tom had shown her at
the beginning of the movie meanwhile
hester is still asleep aboard the old
couple's vehicle when tom wakes her up
he says that the vehicle has turned
south so the couple has lied to them tom
finds a way out under the floor but
hester cannot jump off because of her
injury he refuses to go without her and
both are soon caught they are then held
hostage and put up for slave auction in
a town hester is almost bought by a man
when suddenly a girl that stands out
from the crowd claims hester for herself
the auctioneer recognizes the girl as a
wanted criminal and member of the
anti-traction league anna fang
she kills the auctioneer in a single
shot and asks tom and hester to run away
however they do not get far before
suddenly the cyborg from earlier who
wanted to kill hester arrives hester
recognizes him as shrike shrike
approaches the two as they run away from
him he almost gets them but they are
saved by anna again anna then flies them
in her airship and tells hester she
looks like her mother sensing the two's
curiosity hester reveals how she knows
shrike it turns out that he had found
her after valentine killed pandora and
ever since has been her parent shrike
raised her and helped her survive in the
world he is the only cyborg left after
all of his kind were killed one day
shrike was fed up with always seeing
hester sad so he made an exoskeleton
with the intention to transform her into
a cyborg as well hester promised him
that she would go through with the plan
but found out about valentine's
whereabouts right after hence she ran
away and shrike followed her in order to
kill her for breaking the promise tom is
stunned to hear the story the two are
then taken to an airborne city called
the air haven where they meet other
members of the anti-traction league they
have caught up upon valentine's
suspicious activities and know it has
something to do with pandora hence they
have recruited hester to find out more
about valentine's plan hester informs
them of a box that valentine killed her
mother for as they talk about the box
tom remembers the time a worker handed
valentine some old tech used in the
60-second war he finally realizes that
valentine is planning to restart medusa
the weapon that destroyed the earth many
centuries earlier he tells everyone that
the box was the computer course system
to initiate the quantum energy weapon
medusa the only way to stop the weapon
is a crash drive a type of key that
overrides medusa's firing sequence back
in london tom's superior at work herbert
tells valentine about the old tech that
tom had hidden he quickly sends his men
to recruit the devices at the same time
catherine also brings beavis to the
museum but sees that the devices have
already been stolen the museum's
overseer shows them a secret way to
saint paul's cathedral so that the duo
can see valentine's project for
themselves they make their way upstairs
to the church where they see a massive
piece of machinery that valentine calls
medusa it has finally been completed and
is ready for attack they hide behind a
wall and listen to valentine talk about
attacking shen guo just then the current
lord mayor enters the church and orders
the guards to arrest valentine for
conducting the unlawful experiment
however the guards stay in place
revealing that they work for valentine
now at last he kills the lord mayor as a
horrified catherine watches the two
escape from the stairs later at the air
haven suddenly the lights go off and
shrike arrives looking for hester chaos
ensues as the whole city lights on fire
tom and hester run away from shrike but
he battles with the anti-traction league
members and soon catches up with the two
he is about to kill tom when hester begs
him not to seeing her crying for someone
shrike realizes that she has finally
found someone she loves and isn't
unhappy anymore that means he doesn't
have to convert her into a cyborg a
severely injured shrike hands hester the
necklace pandora had given her and dies
instantly hester tom and the members of
the anti-traction league now make their
way to the city of shen guo they meet
shenghuo's governor quan and tell him of
valentine's plan anna suggests he helped
launch the anti-tractionist fleet
against london because if they strike
first the chances of shenghuo's survival
are less
quan orders the guards to strike at
london before they strike them tom
retaliates saying that innocent
londoners should not be punished for
valentine's mistakes quan claims that if
there was another way to defend his city
he would then everyone starts to prepare
for the battle as tom walks away annoyed
hester and an anti-tractionist league
member sathya pray when hester notices
that the necklace her mother gave her
has a crash drive inside she and tom
quickly run to anna to tell her about
the finding however right then valentine
launches the first attack on the shield
wall and destroys it partially it sends
the city of shanghua into havoc people
are pushed around because of the force
created by the explosion immediately
after the first strike valentine orders
to recharge the system and launch the
second strike however the recharge will
take some time after getting the crash
drive anna and the others from the
anti-tractionist league along with
hester and tom get on their respective
ships and fly towards london intense air
combat ensues between the two cities
many of the anti-tractionist league's
members are killed in the battle but
anna tom and hester ascend unharmed anna
manages to hover the aircraft above
london and hester gets inside taking the
crash drive with her sometime later she
makes tom handle the aircraft and gets
herself to london as well she attacks
valentine up front to distract him so
that hester can use the drive to
override the system now only 60 seconds
are left for the missile to be launched
but hester manages to stop it in the
last few seconds valentine looks over at
hester when anna asks her to run away he
then pushes anna from a platform killing
her valentine finally confronts his
daughter catherine outside and asks her
to come with him to a safe place she
belittles him for killing everyone for
power and runs inside inside the control
room of london valentine's men kill all
the operators enraged with his first
plan not working valentine has decided
to crash the whole of london into the
shield wall to break it catherine tries
to pull the brakes but the system has
been corrupted she tells tom about the
situation through a radio tom then asks
catherine to open the engine's gate he
flies inside the engine system in his
aircraft and destroys the engines by
launching missiles in the hopes of
stopping london from colliding with the
wall at the same time valentine gets on
an aircraft to take off and avoid the
crash himself however hester confronts
the man and points her gun at him they
get into a fight and hester remembers
her mother had an affair with valentine
the thought distracts her and valentine
gets the upper hand
at last she manages to free herself and
latch on to tom's aircraft when she is
safe tom launches a missile at
valentine's aircraft and finally kills
him london stops seconds before crashing
into the wall and all the residents come
outside
they walk to shen guo in the hopes of
starting a new life the movie ends as
tom and hester hug promising to travel
the world with one another subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching